si je vous dis enfant unique vous pensez
forcément à la chine cette politique
restés pour la plupart d'entre nous
comme un vague souvenir de nos cours
d'histoire change radicalement
la chine compte déjà 1,4 milliard
d'habitants mais le 31 mai elle a
autorisé les familles à avoir trois
enfants sur le site du figaro vous vous
interrogez sur cette démarche
certains craignant même une volonté du
pays d'étendre sa domination
alors pourquoi la chine est passée de la
doctrine de l'enfant unique a fait des
gosses la réponse dans facture
[Musique]
d'abord sortez votre trousse et votre
cahier faisons un petit rappel
historique dans les années 70 la chine
était déjà le pays le plus peuplé et de
loin alors le gouvernement entreprend de
contrôler sa démographie des 71 mais
c'est en 1979 que deng xiaoping lance
officiellement la politique de l'enfant
unique
dans un premier temps pour éviter la
surpopulation et ses risques trop de
monde à nous régaler à loger mais aussi
concentrés les richesses pour favoriser
le développement économique
seulement voilà cette mesure autoritaire
entraînent des drames stérilisation et
avortement forcé enfants cachés
nourrisson noyer ou trafic d'êtres
humains
aujourd'hui même si la natalité a baissé
l'efficacité de cette mesure n'est pas
démontrée
certes la politique de l'enfant unique a
peut-être accéléré alors processus en
serez hors probablement un résultat
aujourd'hui est aussi petit à petit il y
a eu de plus en plus d' exception à
cette mesure ont pu déroger à la règle
les familles qui habitent dans les
campagnes celles qui ont une fille en
premier enfant
celles issues de minorités ethniques et
enfin les parents eux mêmes
enfant unique en fait c'est en 2016 que
la chine enterre officiellement cette
doctrine et autorise tous les habitants
à avoir deux enfants et en 2021
ce ne sont plus deux mais désormais
trois enfants autorisée et si la chine
en est arrivé là c'est parce qu'elle
vous arrivez des problèmes de taille
le principal c'est le vieillissement
accéléré de la population depuis des
années 90 le pourcentage d'habitants de
plus de 65 ans a doublé
quand dans le même temps la natalité
elle est au plus bas alors la
décroissance démographique
c'est à dire quand il y a plus de décès
que de naissances approche selon les
projections la chine atteindra son pic
entre 2025 et 2030
au moment de se faire dépasser par
l'inde le problème pour la chine c'est
que m un devenir vieille avant d'être
riche que le pays est encore très loin
d'avoir atteint le niveau de
développement de pays développés comme
en europe aux états unis et la chine
craint pour son économie
car qui dit baisse de la natalité dit
moins de main d'oeuvre et cela risque de
plomber le dynamisme du pays
je veux savoir millions de personnes
actives
que cette opération va réduire de plus
de 200 millions à l'horizon 2050 cette
population active
historique a été la chine au cours des
trente dernières années conséquence
baisse des salaires et des retraites
la chine devra alors consacrer davantage
de dépenses pour régler ces problèmes
sociaux et inciter les familles à avoir
des enfants mais les chinois ne sont pas
forcément demandeurs et l'autorisation
d'avoir deux enfants n'a pas dopé la
natalité incitatif la société s'est
modernisée et les mentalités ont changé
résultat les chinois ne veulent pas
forcément de famille nombreuse pour des
raisons qui peuvent être économiques
chinois comme beaucoup de pays de la
région sont obsédés par la qualité
l'éducation ou qu'ils vont dépenser sans
compter pour que leurs enfants aillent
dans les meilleurs cours privés ou ne
veut pas vous permettre d'avoir un
enfant et simplement l'envoyer à l'école
publique ça ne suffit pas il faut lui
payer des cours
compiègne des cours d'anglais de cours
de 2 coding tout ce que vous voulez mais
aussi parce que la famille n'est plus
forcément la priorité pour beaucoup de
jeunes aujourd'hui qui veulent profiter
de leur jeunesse ou se concentrer sur
leur carrière
contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait
penser ce n'est pas pour dominer
monde que la chine autorise un troisième
enfant mais plutôt pour régler ses
propres problèmes et je crois qu'en
europe on essaye à bourges en contre
tendance à projeter sur elle une
puissance qu'elle n'a pas la trajectoire
pour l'avenir n'est pas forcément une
chine qui conquiert le monde comme on
imagine une chine qui a des gros
problèmes et il faut les résoudre
on peut même se demander si ce n'est pas
trop tard pour relancer la natalité
baisse et quartz de secoirs de naissance
pour savoir si la chine a réussi à
relancer ces naissances
on se donne rendez vous d'ici plusieurs
années